so what we ain't go so ugly treaty we
just sitting good in the sgb so are we
ladies that's how it's supposed to be
66 don't wanna free
so we ain't no so ugly treaty we just
sitting good in the SG I guess Fung
brothers Fung brothers not the brand
have been doing entertainment together
for a while now four years since college
especially and then we always grew up
rapping and he's and when he started
rapping icer rapping so we've been
basically rapping together for a long
time and doing performances but the Fung
brothers that brand started about a year
and a half ago when we moved down to LA
when we were in Seattle we were doing it
separately and together on like specific
occasions but had never really
necessarily occurred to us to like brand
it fun brothers because we were always
just like Andrew funk David Fung people
would call us the Fung brothers but that
wasn't like an official name and then
when we came down we're like oh that
would be like a really good way to to do
it we can all like you could just
perform together and brand most of our
gigs together too and it's also I think
it's more dynamic to for like the
audience and maybe especially if you
people grew up with siblings maybe they
can relate to sort of relationship so
different I think then one it's easier
we have two minds working for the same
thing where we already spend all the
time together we live together so great
and work together and then it's it's
more distinct you know like it's
different
for people like where are there two
other Asian brothers that do comedy and
wrap together
we had a lot of Asian friends in college
but yeah where we grew up from from up
until high school we were it was like a
predominantly white like blueish collar
town so we got a really good feel of
like what you know it was a very
American experience there was nothing
about it that we're like we did all the
sports going on we were you know trying
to date white girls and doing all this
like you know and then we moved down to
LA to do entertainment and then you know
Koreatown in downtown LA is where we
moved to first and it's a it's just like
a bunch of Korean businesses I would say
more the shock came in college though
and I feel like that's most people like
if they grow up in a predominantly like
white area and just not Asian area
college is just basically every college
across America you can be like II D like
northwestern Wisconsin and there's like
a ton Asians there Asia there every call
there's nothing that Asians love more
than going to college maybe that's the
number one thing
UC Irvine like more than 50 percent
Asian that's crazy
yeah so I think in college it was really
interesting because yeah we came from a
town where everyone's trying to be an
NFL a lot of people trying to be in the
NBA so a lot of people are really
chasing professional sports dreams it's
not like people are thinking about like
becoming the next Bill Gates like it's
not the type of town not a lot of
nervous so happen so it's always
interesting yeah it's definitely
interesting but then moving as far as
moving down goes yeah I mean it's been
it's been crazy and now we live in the
San Gabriel Valley which is literally
over 50% Asian and we're talking about
even specific or vine Irvine is like I
think agents that have had some time and
desire to assimilate a certain amount in
acculturate to American standards and
San Gabriel Valley is not that way
necessarily but that's why that's why we
are we out there in the streets
being asian-american is finding that
sweet spot where you feel comfortable
with both sides we know a lot of people
in our area growing up that were forced
to choose and they were choosing either
like they're kind of their Fabi
traditional culture or they were like
gonna be like whitewash you know and out
Tamia was sad because I was like oh man
you don't got to be this or that you
know like you don't have to like
whitewash yourself and forget all you
this aid cool Asian stuff and then I was
like well you don't have to be stuck
back in Asia you know like kind of
things so for us it took a while you
know of course growing up we probably
went through certain phases where we
kind of wanted to be a little bit more
black or wanted to be a little bit more
white but then you know finally more in
college we kind of became more
comfortable and find that spot where
we're able to take what we like the
positive things of each culture and then
blend them together and so we find Asian
American I actually think where we are
right now diamond jamboree positive
sorry
Diamond Jamboree Plaza Irvine is like a
really agen America this is really Asian
American but it's a specific brand of
Asian America like in NorCal San
Francisco where they have like
descendents of people who worked on the
railroads they also have Asian American
culture it's a little bit different than
this but I think it's all it's still
kind of similar and it depends on also
if you want to take on more of like your
specific ethnicity - American like I
think more people some people feel more
korean-american or some people feel more
Chinese American or Vietnamese American
than they do as a whole like a passion
which is okay but you know either way
you're still taking things you like from
each culture and kind of blending
together and that's the balance is
really what's
it's really cool so and I think that
demographic of people that's growing and
realizing that it's only gonna increase
in time you know don't be we're not
afraid of blending like our Chinese
heritage for like in mixing it with
america so its weird you know people i
think it's actually very unkind 'is what
we're doing it's like we're rapping
about Chinese food rap is like so unch I
need it's like this Western art form to
say actually black like came from black
American art form you know specifically
and then we're blending it with you know
traditional Asian food or talking about
these things that we like so so I see I
think in a way and I'm not saying this
like in a way to be like I think some of
them are Metiria actually was in in the
in the prior range of what was
considered Asian American and like I
think we even like this is the generally
accepted canon of what's asian-american
and like we even like it like a little
bit further than that like pulling from
really polar opposites like I you we I
rapid Mandarin a little bit like not as
much anymore of it like we used to try
to rob the Mandarin which is like a
language that people in China don't even
really wrap in like a little bit but not
really so I think it's even it's
difficult to say I mean it's weird
because you know if you represent the
San Gabriel Valley San Gabriel Valley is
such a overwhelmingly Chinese area
it's not even asian-american in some
ways so I think that we include aspects
they even people who are not familiar
with the Asian I did I pays an American
identity and only familiar with the
Chinese identity can still relate to it
so it's a little fob year actually than
ten Asian American so it's like Asian
American plus I guess age American at
one point five Asian American 2.0 yeah
because I think is like it's it's
interesting because Asian America right
we have this concept that's been
developed by a kadhi
and through people around us but what a
lot of times people don't realize they
don't think about it maybe they realize
it there's a constant influx of
immigrants from Asia every day and it's
only like actually gonna increase as
much as America allows it basically as
many visas is the issue people are
trying to come over so Asian America is
actually always always changing because
it's not like other immigrant groups
they like came in a rush and then that
was the group like Italian Americans
like Irish Americans they came in a rush
and there was no like constant influx of
Irish Americans every year after that
for Asian Americans there will be
forever into this country so I think
that actually makes the narrative even
more dynamic and have so many facets so
complicated is a good way and it like we
said it's kind it can be very
complicated and that's why a lot of
people choose one or the other and
that's and we understand why people do
that but if you if you take the time to
think about it and really find it it's
really cool
well my sister's an engineer she went to
Stanford so she did my parents cowboy
they got one a model minority kid go
Tracy gonna do you so much because I
don't know we hate them such a taking
the right thing off us a little bit
we're still the Sun so we you have to
prove something you know I think it's up
to any kid who's not gonna follow the
traditional rally and go against you
know what the parents believe or do
something new it's on you to do it well
enough or have the passion to show your
parents and convince them that this is a
good move I think they already saw that
we had the passion for it and you know
thank God that they were liberal enough
to let us experience and dabble in that
stuff growing up and then they saw us
come down here and I think they were
skeptical like oh maybe it's kind of
like a kind of like a grad school type
thing like healed me back in like two
three years you know they're just gonna
like try it out or like maybe they'll
find like a good job down there they
still their degrees still pursue repeat
our page yeah still maybe eventually go
to UCLA and write a dissertation on
entertainment which is like my dad's
dream but not happening we well maybe I
don't know but like so yeah we but we've
done enough and we've got enough press
enough press especially being on Chinese
television helps your Chinese parents
understand and then also having their
friends kids maybe like ask about us and
talk about what we're doing basically
you you have to give your parents
something to brag about
exactly there's they really like
bragging about their kids and comparing
them stacking them up against each other
give them something to brag about just
anything just it could even be being in
like the Chinese American newspaper like
but if that's what your parents care
about and their friends care about and
that's what's relevant to their like 10
15 friends that's all you need man so
that's our advice to any kids who want
to get out it's on you give it any
something quickly get in the lay in in a
publication of your parents home
language
or get their kids their friends kids
somehow jealous you're talking about you
there's a basically parents friends kids
it's like our videos thank you
I feel like the most comments I get are
actually not from people from Asia
people from Asia they I think especially
if they're in America or they study the
English language there's a little bit of
sense of like yeah we know like we come
from this and you guys like we're really
different but I do think like maybe some
like they still like feel really
conflicted cuz they're like we're just
American like everybody else why do you
guys have to keep emphasizing their
we're Asian and I think that that is I
understand where that train of thought
comes from that was actually a very
specific period in Asian American
history like the assimilate model and
all the things that come from that I'm
not you know whatever you know everybody
can feel how they want to feel about it
but we always just let people know you
know we own up to it like it's almost
like martial arts like people say oh you
know like to be kind of like I don't
know how to feel when people are like oh
do you know kung fu like that sounds
like a stereotypical question right but
that's actually one of the greatest
exports as far as like a cultural export
that people all around the country
around the world would have known
nothing but they'd never even had orange
chicken one time but they loved maybe
they even practice wushu or something
because they watched a Bruce Lee movie
and they and it touched them so deeply
these Eastern philosophies and a lot of
the Eastern philosophies that form kung
fu still inform Asia to a certain extent
to this day you know so I think that
American the way it's been presented has
made it cheesy it's sort of like dragons
and tigers is like that stuff is it's
cheesy not because it's actually cheesy
in the world but within the context of
our lives of how we've been raised we've
been kind of being raised to be like hey
man like what are you saying I don't
know kung fu for I think I think the
best is not to pretend like people are
not different but to understand the
differences and love each other for and
embrace it you know that's people want
I'm never gonna be a better white person
than a white person even if I try I
tried I'm not a better right person so I
you know I owned up to the culture that
part of the culture that I loved
and uh you know I think the way I look
at it is like your people are like oh
don't define me by my ethnicity I'm not
defined by my ethnicity
not everybody is but let's let's be
honest like your ethnicity helps to find
your culture and your culture helps to
find you so that's like indirectly yes
it does impact where you know if I'm
Chinese I probably came from a Chinese
culture that Chinese culture is impact
in my life and the things I like and my
life experiences cool that has helped to
find me so in a way you know it's almost
like yeah it comes kind of comes back to
that stigma because it's like people
people wouldn't shy away from those
stereotypes so much if they didn't have
it embedded in their head that it was
bad to be that stereotype yeah you know
I mean oh I don't eat rice every day
like you know you always have to defend
yourself when you're going up oh why
don't you rice every song with e rice
what if you do it like I mean I know I
had a lot of white friends at 8:00 like
steak and potatoes literally like six
times a week my Mac days but they loved
it they were like proud of that they
were like yeah I'm a state containers
type of guy and it was like but then
because we're in America we feel like we
need to shy away from like yeah I'm a
rice everyday type of guy you never hear
anybody own that it's so strong but
maybe we should you know cuz that's
maybe that's real like ice probably
every meal that I was home with my
parents like for sure rice or noodles oh
that's real to me nothing wrong with it
I like don't rice you know I just don't
I think a lot of people have an
inferiority complex but it's a culture
that's basically it it's like you you
look you think your culture is inferior
so you shy away from it and we're just
like well just don't think it's inferior
and just make it better like you know
like oh well what do you mean like what
do you mean my oh look at my eyes
seriously they are way more slanted than
a white person's eyes like like look at
me like this is doesn't happen to other
white night like when I smile at they
just close and I think I guess so see
yeah I remember there's this player in
the MLB I forgot his name but he's a
he's half Japanese he's half chinese and
half Peruvian he came from Peru and he's
in the MLB and I remember during one of
the Thai
on-camera interviews there was one of
his Hispanic teammates was behind him
doing this right
and a lot of people you know of course
media went you know not media went
really crazy but some people were like
really questioning him and he goes yeah
he goes I'm not ashamed of my eyes I
really like the way my eyes look he's
like I think my eyes look sexy and then
I was just like yeah like that's how
people should look at it because I mean
[ __ ] I mean you got round eyes you got
some or whatever like but I think if you
buy into that standard that round eyes
is better that's gonna be like you're
gonna start to be like what do you mean
and I look I don't think everybody's on
that level where they feel confident
enough to defend themselves on that
level and I understand so but it's gonna
get to that point and with more and more
people like him or other proud like tons
of all these youtubers or like us you
know we're gonna contribute and that's
gonna eventually build into people who
don't feel that way anymore but I think
for the now for this time being they're
still gonna be a lot of people who feel
inferior which is too bad but I mean
that's its life its take steps it takes
steps you know when you are basically a
minority group that's entering like a
dominant culture of anywhere I mean this
happens there was if it was the flip
reverse like let's say like non Asian
people were immigrating to Asian
countries it would be the same way like
people would wish they had like like
smaller like slavery irises so it's just
it's just whatever is the dominant
narrative fm
a rule we have is that if you're gonna
do it Asian accent it's got you've got
to try to be as accurate as possible to
us we're not I'm not amazing at accents
I got a couple accents I can do pretty
well so I I try to stick to those or if
I try a different when I do try hard to
be as accurate as possible
we don't take cheap shots really at
different groups that are not involved
in the skit or have nothing to do with
the skate like we won't just throw in
like a jab at Indian people out of
nowhere like that's totally unfair
no one should do that but like yeah if
it's the skit about Chinese people or
Korean people or Vietnamese people then
yeah you know just just try to be we try
to be accurate but yeah in the end still
poking I think a lot of it where where
it comes from and yeah always there's
gonna be like not everybody's gonna be
happy with what you say but I think as
long as it comes from a place where it's
more about understanding our differences
then it's fine because people are
different and stuff like that so people
are different that's that's the basis of
this of this interview if nothing else
because of you know like it comes back
to being differences being too complex
to digest so we just try to like put a
facade of like sameness on everything
yeah and try to like blow everything
over and be like oh what do you mean
what you need to say a race for like
what are you like and that goes for Asia
and minorities saying oh yeah this white
girl said to me today and then some
white guys like hey why'd you have to
mention she was right
like you know I mean I mean it works
both ways so it matters you know it's
know worthy but it's about getting the
dialogue and discussion to a level where
everybody feels comfortable taking it
there because if people feel like other
people are so powerful in that
discussion and they're not powerful or
somebody's more educated than them or
has more about understanding then like
that's when feelings get hurt and I
think that that dynamic of what I just
talked about is so complex that our
generation just tries to like pretend
like it doesn't exist which is good in
this bad you know I think I've seen you
know some organizations I've seen like
entire organizations get by on this like
idea of sameness and it works to a
certain extent and then they like just
try to gloss over differences and people
are like
very like hushed about anything that
does come up but I don't know I guess
for me and I'm not gonna judge you know
how if you if you can make it work do it
all over you you do it but like I'm
always like just make just put it out
and then things will get better
eventually blog long term like how about
is addressing systemic issues versus
like band-aids on things systemic issues
if you take one thing away from this
interview is systemic issues system
that's the bottom line that's really
what the kids want to hear of systemic
cool things it's not about dancing and
not about how to be funny just really
systemic issues that if people are
different in systemic issues all right
cool generally pretty much all positive
from the people who watched it there's
an article in the LA Times that came out
which we were like heavily featured in
and then that since being in the LA
Times anything that's in the LA Times is
like under scrutiny high screen really
heavy scrutiny so we did get a little
bit of interesting comments and feedback
from that in the end we believe what
we're doing and we believe would be fair
to what we are and to what other people
want to see us as so we're doing us and
we know that we're positive people and
we're pushing for the greater good of
community the world and everybody so
they can like kind of hate on us or like
criticizes person haters yeah like
honestly it's good like I feel like you
know I had always listened we listen to
a lot of rap music cuz were rappers and
discounters I mean rap music's all about
having haters like rappers love having
haters like and I never really
understood what that meant because when
we were in Seattle maybe we weren't
doing it big enough that we actually
even had anybody talking about us good
or bad so we had no haters and I was
always wondering like man what are we
gonna have haters like I just want to
have some haters please and then finally
after 66 came out and the things that
happen from
like the LA Times article and stuff like
that then we finally started getting
some haters so I was like man that's
good because I actually realized that
hating on someone takes a lot of energy
because that's someone breaking from
their normal routine of their life you
know you have this thing that they do
the world they live to get on the
computer read the entire article like
think of things they don't like about
you think about you watch your videos
come up with something that they think
you stand for and then tell you they get
furious about it and work themselves in
a little right like maybe four
paragraphs about you and how how you
think it's how they hate on you so it's
thank you you know and it means that
you're doing something that matters the
truth is if no one hates on you you're
probably not doing anything that's
psychic on that level yet what you're
getting you know you're getting shine
for it or your or it's not maybe it's
meaningful what success breeds hate so
yeah more successful more haters
a couple music couples with videos
should be save with your poem say what
it's not gonna be out for I mean uh it's
just one's called friends own one's
called bobalife it's all we need to say
the friends own one you can kind of
guess what it's not about what you think
it is it is theirs we actually have a
web series out right now on one of the
premium YouTube channels we've got to
shoot a show in Texas that was pretty
fun and interesting getting interesting
feedback from that but definitely check
that out if anybody's interested in
seeing some urban asian guys out of
their element in podunk Texas doing some
very like cowboy things which was really
cool and the people were nice by the way
but we just did a spot on Epic Meal Time
they have another show called epic chef
coming out and we did a spot on that and
it was really crazy because we're
sitting on the judging panel and next to
me was Jeannie Mai who's like a
television personality from style two
styl style Network but I used to watch
her back when she was on a ZN TV so this
is like way way way back and then of
this other dude named Tim Ferriss now
Tim Ferriss wrote this book called
4-hour workweek
which is this is crazy because I did a
book report on this maybe I don't want I
want to see my freshman year at college
or like in high school and then I hadn't
thought about him in a long time and
then I met him and I was sitting right
next to him like judging food with Tim
Ferriss guys like mega successful
everybody's like in a different world so
like there's funny because we're at the
she had to shoot for Epic Meal Time
literally nobody knows who he is like
some people know he like wrote a book or
something like that but literally like
in a certain like tech world like
because he's also like a venture
capitalist in Palo Alto or like San
Francisco or whatever like he's like a
really big celebrity but not in like the
entertainment world so it was crazy cuz
I was like oh man like is I my family's
in tech and I kind of knew this guy's
like a like you know Steve job or knew
Steve Jobs
because anyway he's really rich like
nobody nobody knew or nobody's Hannah
Ferris compares if you take anything
away from this interview it's Tim
Ferriss rich Tim Ferriss olive shout-out
to Tim he's cool but it's all crazy
though cuz it just reminded me of like
when you're in the entertainment world
it is such like it
so entertainment focus everybody follows
the same thing so you can like say
things that are relevant with to the
like 50 people in a room not realizing
that like 95 percent of the other parts
of the country don't care about it I
mean so what kind of was like oh man
it's just like everybody's in their own
bubble kind of but some bubbles are
bigger than others you know
in the SGP so are we